the Trump administration and
congressional Republicans are pushing to
overhaul the Endangered Species Act the
45 year old landmark law is helps
safeguard American icons like the bald
eagle and the grizzly bear Republicans
say their plans would modernize the Act
but conservationists say their plants
will gut it Nancy Cordes is at Rock
Creek Park in Washington DC to sort it
all out Nancy good morning to you good
morning what the Endangered Species Act
does is protect the habitat and food
sources of animals who are on the list
and it's a big part of the reason that
bald eagles have returned to this park
after a decades-long absence but
Democrats say it has to be protected
while Republicans argue that there's a
current imbalance between protection and
progress they're pushing nearly a dozen
bills that would make it harder to get a
species on the list easier to take it
off the endangered species act is
credited with bringing gray wolves
Florida manatees and the humpback whale
back from the brink of extinction still
Utah Republican Rob Bishop says the act
is broken
so all we're doing is making lists of
species we're not really rehabilitating
them one of his bills would require the
government to consider not just science
but the cost business before adding a
new animal to the list so you're saying
lettuce species go extinct if it means
that's actually not what I'm saying it's
not at all what I'm saying what I'm
saying is don't specify and limit
yourself into looking at what the
criteria has to be the push has alarmed
conservationists the Endangered Species
Act has been wildly successful Jamie
Rappaport Clark ran the US Fish and
Wildlife Service under President Clinton
Republicans say they just want to
modernize the act modernize is code for
eviscerate undermine what it does is it
rolls back protections for species on
the brink of extinction
but Republicans argue that long term
protections for animals like the spotted
owl hamper logging drilling and
development the goal is to actually help
these species recover Wyoming Republican
John Barrasso spill would turn some of
the federal role for protecting
endangered animals
over to the states I think they have a
lot more understanding of what goes on
in their state as Congress debates the
Trump administration is looking at ways
to act on its own by blocking certain
animals from the list like the
sage-grouse a bird that lives on oil
rich land out west when environmental
groups say you're trying to destroy the
Endangered Species Act you say that's
crap we're trying to make it better so
that if they want to malign me or malign
the process let those radical groups do
it he and his colleagues are trying to
get these bills passed by the end of the
year they're worried that Democrats
could take control of the house after
the midterm elections and John while the
White House can make some of these
changes on its own those changes could
always be rolled back by future
administrations that's why they're
hoping that they can change the law
itself Nancy thanks